level but I think at a cultural level
there's something perhaps even more
important which is we've got to stop
talking down our country I'm a first
generation immigrant to this country and
I get annoyed hearing people talk
endlessly about how we're the worst
country in the world we're the most
sexist country in the world we're the
most racist it's all nonsense this is
one of the best places to live in the
world and that's what we should be
talking about the fact that
sh shame well this is this is exactly
this is exactly the problem that I'm
talking about you are saying shame you
for talking up Britain and that is
exactly the problem we're talking about
this is one of the best places to live
in the world for minorities like me it's
the best place to
be be there's no point in shouting out
for the because because the people at
home can't hear you so so and also let's
not let's try not hang on let's try not
to talk over each other I asked constant
a question we In fairness I have to let
him so we've got to stop we've got to
stop talking down our country we've and
we've got to stop Shou over people who
are talking I've got two minutes left
and I have to let the rest of the panel
answer so let me just do that Ron one